[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 toute l'année
la protection civile des Yvelines
intervient auprès des citoyens sur
différentes thématiques comme les postes
de secours les formations mais aussi
dans le cadre de mission humanitaires et
sociales pour cette année 2023 les
actions de l'association se diversifient
et pour en parler avec nous je suis
aujourd'hui avec Valérie sotojo
vice-présidente de la protection des
Yvelines protection civile pardon des
Yvelines et responsable formation
bonjour bonjour la protection civile est
présente dans toute la France dans le
département des Yvelines vous avez mis
en place de multiples actions pour venir
en aide ou en soutien aux citoyens du
territoire alors quels sont les missions
de l'association au quotidien alors nous
avons trois missions qui sont aidées
donc aider la population à travers par
exemple
l'aide au bénéficiaires donc plus
communément appelé les maraudes mais
aussi l'aide à la population en cas de
catastrophe naturelle inondations
effondrement on a nos collègues par
exemple sur le Nord qui sont intervenus
la suite à l'effondrement des deux
immeubles à Lille voilà par exemple ou
sur Marseille ou voilà toutes les
montées des eaux nous avons eu il y a
quelques années des inondations sur
Vulaines et Poissy nous avons assuré
voilà l'intervention bien évidemment
avec les sapeurs-pompiers qui eux sont
plus présents que nous à ces voilà mais
au moins sur l'accueil de la population
leur offrir à quelque chose de chaud un
lit voilà dans un gymnase ou ce genre de
choses et vous proposez également des
formations tout au long de l'année lors
de quelle formation parle-t-on alors
nous en avons de deux sortes nous avons
celle du grand public à travers ce qu'on
appelle le PSC1 donc c'est la prévention
de ce cours civique de niveau 1 qui est
de 7 heures et qui apprend en fait les
premiers gestes de secours à travers la
protection l'alerte que faire face un
arrêt cardio-respiratoire face à une
hémorragie faire voilà ce genre de
choses une pleine brûlure nous avons une
deuxième un deuxième type de formation
qui est dure deux heures qui les gestes
qui sauvent qui est en fait de l'extrême
urgence face à
un problème avec de nombreuses victimes
cette formation a été mis en place après
le Bataclan pour permettre des gens qui
ne sont pas secouristes d'avoir une
phrase qui pourrait leur permettre
d'intervenir alors à tout moment bien
évidemment aussi dans leur vie privée et
puis nous avons aussi des formations
internes à travers le secours en équipe
qui permet à nos secouristes ou à des
gens qui veulent passer par exemple le
BNSSA de travailler avec du matériel
donc poser un collier cervical une
attelle et puis le second en équipe de
niveau 2 qui a eu leur permet de faire
du relevage et du brancardage
particularité pour nous cette année
c'est qu'en 2023 nous allons mettre en
place de de nouvelles formations les
celles qui concerne le bébé nourrissons
enfant nourrisson donc plus porté vers
les assistantes maternelles ou voilà au
niveau des crèches et puis une formation
seniors qui sera tournée vers alors pour
une partie vers les gens qui peuvent
venir les aides à domicile mais aussi
pour les associations qui concerne les
seniors comme les clubs amitiés voilà
qui permettra d'apprendre au seniors
comment se relever quand on est tombé et
comment éviter justement de tomber par
exemple avec des chaussures qui font des
choses qui ne glissent pas
tapis enfin ce genre de choses voilà et
avoir et encore des bons réflexes alors
l'association fonctionne surtout grâce à
ses nombreux bénévoles alors de combien
de bénévoles parlent-t-on dans les
Yvelines et comment peut-on rejoindre
justement la protection civile alors à
ce jour nous sommes 120 bénévoles d'ici
là fin d'année je pense qu'on arrivera à
130 ou 140 puisque nous avons des
demandes de régulièrement alors pour
nous contacter vous allez sur le site de
la protection civile et vous prenez
l'adresse contact
@protection
civile.org à partir de là vous nous
indiquez ce que vous souhaitez faire
chez nous et puis on vous enverra un
dossier de recrutement nous avons des
réunions de recrutement qui permettent
aux gens d'avoir une présentation de ce
que nous faisons à nos diverses
activités et une fois que vous êtes chez
nous nous assurons votre formation que
ce soit en tant que secouriste en tant
que
maraudeur puisqu'on considère que tout
le monde n'a pas envie d'être secouriste
mais encore une fois l'aide à la
population est prédominant et puis tout
ce qui va être logistique aussi on a
aussi besoin de gens qui nous aident
pour monter une tente du matériel enfin
ce genre de choses
est-ce qu'il y a des conditions
justement pour rejoindre la protection
protection civile du temps alors tout au
long de l'année vous organisez notamment
des des collectes quels sont ces
collectes alors nous avons une collecte
privilégiée qui est celle de Monoprix
pour les bénéficiaires
et puis ensuite nous avons parfois des
collectes à la demande de magasin qui
nous disent voilà on a un stock X ou Y
est-ce que vous êtes intéressé à ce
moment-là on va récupérer le stock qui
nous sert dans 99% pour les maraudes
mais de 2023 sera une année marquée par
la nouveauté vous allez accueillir un
véhicule douche toilette avec un
coiffeur bénévole pour les personnes
sans-abri comment ce projet a-t-il pu
voir le jour et bien c'est nos
secouriste et puis enfin nos maraudeurs
on va les appeler comme ça et puis les
deux responsables de cette activité qui
ont trouvé que
certains avaient une dégradation de
l'hygiène puisqu'ils sont dans la rue et
puis c'est dommage de ne pas pouvoir
leur apporter cette partie d'hygiène
alors on leur fournit un kit hygiène
bien évidemment mais s'il n'y a pas je
dirais la douche ça devient compliqué
donc on a monté un projet avec le
l'équipe technique et logistique de de
notre association ils ont travaillé sur
des plans sur comment faire quel serait
l'utilité comment faire en sorte que
cette ce véhicule soit opérationnel à
100 % et puis on a lancé on a lancé
l'affaire on a présenté le projet à la
préfecture qui a été enthousiasmé et
donc voilà normalement 2023 il devrait
arriver alors l'objectif c'est que ce
véhicule traverse le département toute
l'année ce que vous avez déjà une idée
des villes justement vous allez vous
vous rendre alors nous avons une
application sur une tablette qui nous
permet de recenser d'avoir une idée de
où se trouve dans la plupart du temps
nous bénéficiaires donc bien évidemment
les premières communes sont celles où il
y en a le plus et puis ensuite bien
évidemment nous pourrons nous déplacer à
la demande d'une mairie qui aurait
un nombre conséquent ou en tout cas
quelques-uns de
bénéficiaires qui auraient besoin de
cette hygiène et d'Amérique on ne voit
pas obligatoirement puisque le
département est plutôt séparé en
diverses associations donc il y a des
communes que nous n'assurons pas
obligatoirement donc on n'a pas toujours
cette vision et plusieurs antennes vont
également ouvrir dans les Yvelines
pourquoi ouvrir d'autres antennes sur le
département est-ce que vous estimez
justement que la protection civile n'est
pas assez présente sur le territoire ou
c'est simplement pour pérenniser vos
actions sur le département alors je vous
ai l'association a repris vie je dirais
en 2011 sur Vilaine puisque la commune a
bien voulu nous accueillir
nous avons donc fait repartir tout
doucement cette association on n'était
pas nombreux et puis au fur et à mesure
on s'est aperçu que on avait de plus en
plus de demandes que ce soit pour les
pose de secours pour les formations et
ils nous est impossible de dire oui à
toutes ces demandes si on ne fait pas un
maillage ils sont créés pas de d'autres
entités dans le département donc à ce
jour nous avons septoï qui vient
d'ouvrir donc pas très loin de Mantes
nous avons Versailles qui ouvre nous
avons les boucles de scène plutôt sur
oui pour situer à peu près et puis
depuis 2022 outre l'innovation de ce
camion douche en 2023 nous avons créé en
2021 une unité équestre première unité
équestre nationale au niveau de la
protection civile qui intervient sur des
poses de secours qui sont plutôt les
trails en forêt ou des voilà des des
lieux plutôt difficiles d'accès pour nos
véhicules ou même pour nous en tant que
pédestre et puis on travaille aussi avec
tout ce qui va être les services publics
pour par exemple les recherches de
personnes disparues alors justement ce
vous avez parlé de 120 120 bénévoles
avec des antennes justement qui ouvre ça
peut aussi ouvrir des portes à plus de
bénévoles plus d'action tout à fait
encore une fois nous nos actions que je
vous dis je vous donnais tout à l'heure
que ce soit aider secourir et former
nous allons les développer sur tout le
département donc bien évidemment notre
but est de former plus de gens de
pouvoir demander à des gens de
s'investir pour participer avec nous à
nos missions de tous les jours et
peut-être avoir des gens qui sont très
très motivés pour avoir un objectif qui
est 2024 et l'ambition c'est aussi de
créer un maillage sur le territoire
notamment à travers les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques 2024 alors quels sont
les ambitions justement pour pour 2024
alors à ce jour la protection civile n'a
pas d'ambition ou d'objectif puisque
nous sommes toujours en appel d'offres
au niveau national donc on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas en parler et de toute
façon je ne peux pas vous répondre
puisque nous ne savons pas les résultats
donc en fait ce qu'on fera c'est se
mettre au service et de notre fédération
et de la préfecture s'il y a une demande
et nous assurons les demandes que
qui sont faites c'est pour ça que nous
avons besoin de secouristes mais vous
êtes prêts la protection civile est
prête
à travers un développement
un accroissement des déformations on va
parler un petit peu de un petit peu de
vous justement pour cette fin d'émission
qu'est-ce qui vous a donné envie de
rejoindre l'association et pourquoi
faut-il donner un peu de son temps aux
autres selon alors moi j'ai rejoint la
protection civile en 1991 tout
simplement parce que j'ai l'habitude une
petite commune du Val d'Oise ou il y
avait une protection civile qui était là
sur toutes les fêtes surtout un voilà et
comme j'étais un petit peu chat noir
j'avais tendance à aller régulièrement
les voir pour une luxation de coude ou
ce genre de choses donc voilà et ça m'a
plu c'est une deuxième famille voilà
c'est c'est vraiment une deuxième
famille et puis il va donner du temps
c'est bien parce qu'en fait vous avez un
enrichissement incroyable vous
rencontrez plein de gens des différentes
voilà différentes sociétés différents
milieux et puis je crois que ça vous
remet aussi un peu les pieds sur terre
en disant bon on n'est pas si malheureux
que ça des fois et c'est de toute façon
la solidarité qui fait avancer le monde
le monde et la société merci beaucoup
Valérie sauté d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation donc je rappelle que vous êtes
vice-président de protection civile des
Yvelines est responsable formation pour
plus d'informations peut se rendre sur
le site
yvelines.protection-civile.org et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]